[Musique]
[Musique] à l'
extérieur autant que possible, c'est l'
option la plus sûre
[Musique]
m'aide à me concentrer davantage sur le travail, il est
plus heureux maintenant qu'il est de retour à l'école,
je pense qu'il accorde une meilleure attention maintenant
qu'il est ici
tellement mieux à l'extérieur  devant les
enfants, une bien meilleure
classe dégoulinant d'eau acide a fait
une expérience de sécurité minimaliste.
moi ce que j'étais censé faire
parce que les restrictions ont
trop de sens
c'est difficile pour finlay
sélectionné c'était vraiment difficile ma femme et moi
travaillons tous les deux à plein temps
la paix
je pense que cela a aidé sa performance et
il va beaucoup mieux
c'est vraiment vraiment un ensemble crucial